i
tire of the empty battles i once created
i wonder outcast
while my tribe curses the gods who
abandoned us
our home is in ruins
yet i stand firm
six days ago the falling star
struck the town of tristram
the dead rose in its wake
what evil is this
could it be what i have sought these
long years
a foe worthy of my blade
this place reeks of death the fallen
star is near
so
i seek the fallen star it fell on the
old cathedral
there was only one survivor captain
rumford are coming
we can't open the gates
they keep coming
the ancients drunk never seen anyone
fight like that before
gods open the gates you'll find lea at
the slaughtered calf inn
burn those corpses before they rise
[Music]
again
rumford said you survived the fallen
star i did
but it blasted my uncle deckard kane
into the depths of the old cathedral
i tried to search for him but the dead
were already rising i came back here to
rally the militias
[Music]
this is killing business
the dead will overwhelm us all unless
somebody i will send them back to their
grave thank you
you should speak with
you